on the titties underrated
anyway
going back to Top Gun though I've
definitely grown more of an appreciation
to any action films with Tom Cruise in
them just because have you guys been
like been recommended the clips and the
shorts that are just basically a bunch
of Tom Cruise interviews describing all
the stunts that he's done no bro that
man Tom Cruise as we know is [ __ ]
insane right but he's the right kind of
insane to make amazing action movies
right right because he is very like old
school when it comes to stunts and
everything like that how do you do all
of his stunts right now he does I don't
know if he does all of them but a lot of
them he does by himself so one of the
craziest stunts I haven't even seen the
movie but one of the craziest stunts
I've heard
um him talk about recently was in one of
the recent Mission Impossible movies
they do like a Halo jump
uh and what's a Halo jump that it's
where you like jump from like the
stratosphere I think yeah yes I believe
it's like okay can we fact check exactly
what a Halo jump is
um but basically it's a Skydive it's a
Skydive skydive from space it's a
skydive from space right see we're not I
don't know if it's one space but it's a
it's either a very low or very high
skydive I'm gonna guess very high right
a very low would just be a fall
I meant either a low out shoe than usual
or higher out to you I think it's higher
uh well Halo stands for high altitude
low openings okay
[Music]
yeah right from the stratosphere right
I'm pretty sure or it's like above the
stratosphere or something anyway it's a
really high score yeah so in this movie
because after him after watching him
talk about it I actually went out and
watched the scene in this movie and it's
it's one long shot right it's one
[ __ ] long shot of them jumping out of
the airplane and then there's this
there's this in entire [ __ ] action
sequence that happens mid-air and it's
all done like IRL in real life where
what about IRL stands for yeah yeah
I just just in case the views in though
okay well one of one of the guys gets
like struck by lightning that's
obviously CG but obviously he passes out
and Tom Cruise has to basically help him
fix this helping he gets hit by
lightning mid Skydive yeah yeah yeah how
unlucky
be fair they do the halo jump in a
thunderstorm so so you know you know
it's not like kind of asking for it it's
not like they just jump out of the plane
and then God's just like I'm going to
Smite this one person you made it sound
like it was like Clear Blue Skies and
it's just like one strike it's like
unfortunate yeah so yeah Tom Cruise's
character has to help him fix
um fix his parachute and fix everything
in mid-air yeah um and then they [ __ ]
are able to just land safely I guess
afterwards but
it's all done in one show it's one
unbroken shot right
and Tom Cruise was talking about it and
they only had one take a day right
because it was shot right as the sun was
Rising yeah so they had one take a day
to do like this three to four minute
shot right which was a highly Advanced
skydiving technique and sky and Skydive
uh skydiving sequence where
what happens is the first shot is like
the camera guy had to literally fly out
and Tom Cruise had to fly out and he had
to catch up to the camera guy to like I
believe a few inches because it needed
to be in Focus right he needed he needs
to catch up the cameraman and stop
mid-air at the right length for the
camera to be in Focus right before going
off past the cameraman and that just
that's [ __ ] insane how insane do you
have to be to
choreography huh I want to see the
yellow takes I'm just like well Chris is
running into the camera now my head
first yeah it's it definitely hearing
him talking about it and now watching
back to the sequence it's definitely
given me way more of an appreciation to
some of the [ __ ] that he does on screen
in his action movies because I haven't
seen Top Gun but I've heard everything
was also done with the same kind of
mindset where we're not doing we're not
using CG we're doing as much of this in
real life as we possibly can that stuff
was crazy in that movie yeah what was
the action scenes like in that movie oh
like nuts like you do because it's all
like real Jets I'm pretty sure yeah at
least for most of it and yeah it's just
crazy scenes like really cool uh like
choreographed scenes between two Jets as
well like yeah I don't know it's sick
it's a great movie go watch it you'll
love it if you if you have an
appreciation for that you'll you'll like
talking I mean I loved the original Top
Gun so yeah yeah it's almost homo erotic
sadly it's not oh which is you know I
don't know
yeah well because this one's more of
like a he's like a mentor I was ready to
take my [ __ ] top tier boxes with me
as well and everything just to me the
first one is just about you know uh him
being struggling with his gay identity
which yeah have you seen that Quentin
tarantine
there's this good short like Tarantino
is just [ __ ] talking about how top
kind of secretly a movie about gay guys
yeah like someone discovering their home
um the homosexual side yeah in Top Gun
isn't just a movie about boys playing
volleyball
Quentin Tarantino clip you could ever
[ __ ] imagine and just what's what's
funnier is just you see this clip you
scroll down to the comments and it's
just it's sometimes YouTube comments
like they double the uh the
entertainment clip they're like so this
is a Wendy's
that's so good oh my God we're not like
another film I watched recently because
I don't know I don't actually watch many
films it's uh everything everywhere all
at once you guys watch that as well
recently pretty good [ __ ] incredible
amazing came at the same time as Dr
Strange and it's way better than it yeah
yeah exactly oh my God it's such a good
movie Choo choose which Multiverse
[ __ ] Multiverse of Badness and
Multiverse the the main goal is the same
actress in uh crashing tiger I think
yeah yeah Michelle yo Michelle yeah the
movie was amazing yeah I didn't know she
could speak English yeah yeah oh she
speaks perfectly yeah yeah well no no no
no no because I'm crashing tiger she
doesn't right well I because she's a
really really famous actress in China
I've only seen her speaking you know
Mandarin or Cantonese so I didn't know
if she could speak English or not and uh
yeah I didn't I didn't realize like how
much of that film is spoken in Chinese
I thought it was I I [ __ ] loved it
yeah because that was really really cool
yeah because there are some films
like uh what's the other film what's
what's the film uh where it's a girl
meets a really really rich guy
um and it's like also based in like Asia
and [ __ ]
the one that was filmed in Malaysia yeah
oh [ __ ]
is every Asian romance just like [ __ ]
filmed in Malaysia but Romeo and Juliet
I have to have to have to look look oh
[ __ ] Michelle yo was in that as well I
completely forgot oh my god of course
you can speak English I'm a [ __ ]
clown oh my God this is it's it's it's
it's on the [ __ ] tip of my tongue uh
why are you thinking about that though
like I think the one thing I really
appreciate about everything everywhere
was just like how I mean for one it's
[ __ ] hilarious yeah like but actually
like it's on the nose but it's not like
cheesy I guess it's really good and also
it's just really [ __ ] shot well yeah
like it's almost like it was almost like
an odd house it really watching that
gave me the same Vibes not not exactly
the same like tone but the same Vibes
it's like watching The Matrix for the
first time where they just had this
really really interesting idea yeah
right and they turned it into they they
took this concept which in The Matrix
was it's all virtual world and you can
break the rules of this virtual world
become a Kung Fu Master and all that
yeah I had that I had that he had that
same kind of vibe where is this like
Anything Could Happen yeah Anything
Could Happen yeah and it was a really
interesting concept and they explored it
in the most intro interesting way
possible yeah I felt like Everyone Cared
in that movie like every every every
little detail that yeah it felt like it
was really done to the utmost uh you
know like even some of the fight scenes
yeah the camera angles were oh my God
some of the corio feels crazy I mean I
mean we know that Michelle yo can fight
you know he's been in a lot in a lot of
action films
um so it was just yeah it was just a
[ __ ] because it was so weird because
it's like I feel any other movie would
like take the same Concepts that
everything everywhere had uh and would
just like really [ __ ] dumb it down to
the point where you wouldn't be able to
take it seriously like the bagel for
instance yeah yeah right like that like
that scene like was like I remember when
I was watching that I was just like oh
okay this is kind of dumb but then by
the end of it I was just like no The
Bagel like I was so invested in and I
was like don't go into the bagel I'm
like
um and I just like stood back I'm just
like what am I saying why am I why am I
investing in this [ __ ] bagel yeah
it's it's one of the most refreshing
films I've seen yeah in a very very long
time I mean speaking of Matrix you're
saying I also watch Matrix resurrections
yes no it's Resurrection Revelations is
the uh [ __ ] needs a resurrection bro
yeah oh my God no it did not need a
residency
Top Gun if Top Gun is the perfect
example of a a lot you know a long
franchise coming back in a modern way
and it being and it being successful
yeah Matrix resurrections is the
opposite where they just tried to throw
in as much fan service as possible and
they try to be way too meta to the point
where it's just [ __ ] dumb I think
there's only like one person in the
world that enjoyed Enrique's
resurrection and that's the one person
who wrote that script on fanfiction.com
yeah because that's what it [ __ ] felt
like oh my god did you watch it I
watched it yeah I haven't watched it
just the whole meta of the fact that's
not so bad just the whole matter of the
fact that like Keanu Reeves's character
is the one that like he's a game
developer who created The Matrix Games
and then like Sony Entertainment is just
like we want you to make the next Matrix
game but it's actually the movie that
you're currently watching somewhere I
don't know but I think I think we might
as I think I might have mentioned I feel
like I've had this conversation I can't
remember if it's been on camera or off
but I think that someone gets my yeah
the one thing though that I think pissed
me off the most yeah yeah I think the
one thing though that pissed me off the
most more than that was the fact that
they replaced uh Smith and Morpheus with
two different actors yeah yeah I'm just
like I I want Lawrence Fishburne I don't
know I don't know who this other guy is
but he's not he's not my Morpheus well
launch fish runs in John Wick yeah but
but
that's the new Matrix
I want the Hugo weaving mystery because
we've got this [ __ ] like when you
have Lawrence Fishburne and uh John Wick
when they meet in the thing you can feel
the energy yeah I can tell he's like he
like [ __ ] yeah how you doing
it's good I heard though that like they
didn't even like hit up Lawrence
Fishburne
new movie and it's like how could you
not like he's such a pivotal yeah but
like he's such a pivotal actor in the
The Matrix fantastic and same with Hugo
weaving as well yeah yeah and then
replaced Mr Smith instead of Hugo
weaving like Chad mode they replaced him
with this [ __ ] like he's a frat boy
he's a fat he's a frat boy man's a human
fist bump yeah like what the [ __ ] do
they do to him yeah he's like he's like
the Silicon Valley like crony that you
would never want to be friends with I'm
just waiting for John Wick 4 now because
that's that got a it's trailer recently
oh really oh yeah it's got announced I'm
pretty sure yeah end of 2023 maybe well
hopefully they don't do a matrix I'm
sure I'm sure it's gonna be one two and
three were amazing I'm sure four will be
amazing yeah
I've watched the first one yeah I've
watched the first one yeah and I do want
to watch the other two I just haven't
had the time I don't watch many movies I
don't really know what's going on but
it's such a joy to watch yeah I think
it's everything because it's such I
never go back and watch the previous
movie so I remember one quite well
because plot was simple yeah right and
then two if something happens yeah and
I'm not sure and then three I'm just
watching it and I'm thinking yes but the
choreography is just amazing I mean you
basically just describe the Matrix yeah
as well it's so good like the fight
scenes are so good in John Wick it's
just such a joy going back to uh going
back to everything everywhere all at
once what I was trying to remember the
film I was trying to remember was crazy
Rich Asians oh yeah yeah I I was
genuinely gonna say that as a meme
because I thought that's what no that's
that's literally I I didn't think that
was the movie you were talking about oh
no no I was gonna Meme and say that what
was that because I was saying what other
what other film about uh about Asia you
said the word rich and Asian so I was
like yeah yeah that's why I was like
obviously
oh I was like what's the one with the
rich Asians and like kind of crazy
that's why I was going to say it as a
meme because like there's no way it
would be that movie because he would
have remembered because there's only
really one [ __ ] movie about of rich
rich Asians
one of them like meets a rich person and
one of them's poor or whatever oh my God
whatever it was it was crazy Rich Asians
but one one thing that uh one thing that
took me out of that film yeah was the
facts that pretty much everyone spoke
English to that form right and that's
that's what that's what took me out of
that film that's one thing I really
really liked about everything everywhere
all at once because I remember the the
scene that took me out the most out of
crazy Rich Asians was when the mum was
talking to the son and she was speaking
in English and I'm like there's no
[ __ ] way this would happen even if
they're bilingual yeah if if a mum is
scolding a son you know for a fact she's
using her mother tongue there is
absolutely zero [ __ ] way that she's
going to be speaking English and one
thing I [ __ ] loved is that they
didn't give a [ __ ] in uh in everywhere
everything everywhere all at once they
there was such a mix between subtitles
where you know they were speaking
they're speaking Chinese or Mandarin and
there was you know sometimes the
daughter would just reply in English
yeah that's what I like like even in the
opening scene when like the husband and
the the mama talking to each other like
half of it is mean like it's it's like a
yeah perfect mix of like Chinese and
then English and then right back to
Chinese you know like that's so accurate
the real life that's that's so that's
what it's like that's what it would be
like yeah yeah we don't speak English
like some people speak English sometimes
it's a [ __ ] mix sometimes your mum
says something to you in in her mother
tongue and you reply in English because
you can't be asked to [ __ ]
um
even though like the setting for that
movie is so Fantastical the dialogue
felt so real it's it was so grounded in
like it was it it was so grounded in
reality as well in a sense where
characters actually acted uh like how I
recognized like I recognize how they do
in real life yeah and everything as well
yeah um and yeah it just it just made me
it just made me [ __ ] happy to see my
culture represented in this way you know
it's yeah just you know [ __ ] yes I
mean I feel like shows in general that
interweave languages into the story are
generally just like I mean you have to
you're already going out of the way so
much to do that right so like stuff like
narcos breaking bad all those kind of
shows that you get a lot of Spanish
actors and stuff yeah yeah it just it
just makes the world so much more
believable when you have characters that
are that would be bilingual or would
speak X language in that setting yeah
and it just shows that like oh somebody
cared a lot about details yeah you know
I don't give a [ __ ] I have to read some
subtitles for two seconds we're anime
watches yeah yeah exactly
uh maybe you watched that maybe you need
English subtitles I don't know
yeah sometimes maybe you're watching
English shows you're like I don't know
yeah it's like oh my God yeah because
you know obviously we're all bilingual
here and so it's it was just so
refreshing just to see like the
bilingual life you know be be actually
like represented in film because I feel
like for the longest time Hollywood was
just like so scared of subtitles
acceptable oh yeah like the only place I
ever saw it was like World War II movies
some reason World War II movies okay
German bad we subtitle that you know
everywhere else it's just like okay the
bad guys are speaking English and I
don't know why but they're just everyone
just speaks about speaking English just
because like as a director if you're
only fluent in English you might not
have the confidence to be like okay I
trust that these guys can do their thing
yeah I feel I feel yeah now that you say
that that was like the one like tiny
aspect of The Last Samurai that I hated
was the fact that like so in some
instances where I'm like why are you
speaking English you are a [ __ ]
daimyo
and you're just like busting out English
to Tom Cruise I'm like that is not how
we would have played out speak Japanese
I'd like to think wherever Tom Cruise
goes people just start speaking English
yeah yeah it doesn't matter who you are
and then you're like trying to like
damage controller with like Tom Cruise
is like yeah I can learn a couple
Hawaiians of Japanese for this film and
just say it in a really [ __ ] accent it's
like no no no no no no no yeah because I
think like finally we're getting to the
point where more like Multicultural
bilingual people have got have gotten
their way into the movie industry and
can enable are able to handle this at a
level that's you know satisfactory to
the audience yeah because before it was
like yeah you know [ __ ] Germans in
World War II movies or Russians I I I'm
kind of thinking if there's any other
languages that was like subtitled a lot
or like you know any any proper
languages that you see in a lot of
Hollywood films but it's because every
other European language would just be
like oh let's just get an American actor
kind of speaking English in that
country's accent yeah yeah so it's like
if it was like a French character you
would never hear them speaking French
just speak English in a French accent
yeah it's like yeah he's French trust
office if if it was like a [ __ ]
Middle Eastern it was that in the Middle
East then you'd never stop talking to
those characters you know that was just
a that was just a random woman at a
stall yeah that that the [ __ ] perfect
English and then the [ __ ] main
character would be like running through
or some [ __ ] like that you know
that's true yeah sure so yeah watch
everything around all at once one of the
best movies I've seen in a long [ __ ]
time I agree yeah such a good